Hey, what's up, Instagram Live?
It's Girls5eva!
And we're here with a surprise
first look at us in the stude.
The eyeball icon thing is saying zero.
It's just us in here.
It's just us in here!
Oh.
Cease and desist, b******.
Girls5eva are hoping to become
two-hit wonders.
We are officially in album mode.
Finally, we're in charge of the sesh.
No more singing
whatever crap they give us.
Half our old songs
weren't even spellchecked.
We're back in biz.
We need the album
done in six weeks.
That...that's fast.
I know people over 30
tend to have other things in their lives.
I have a kid,
but she never talks to me, so I'm v avail.
Okay!
Girls5eva!
You're a producer?
We got another toxic
dude on our hands!
Cool, cool!
-I don't think I saw him sniff our chair.
-He didn't.
Did he take his d*** out?
Not that I would notice,
they are so boring to me.
We just have to make the
most undeniable album of all time.
-What you got there, Wick?
-My Riff Rolodex.
All the greats are in here.
Yeah! Yeaaaaaahhhhhhhhhh!
Ooooooohhhhhh!
Our album drops in a month.
We need to make noise now!
They're shooting a music video.
How open should my
mouth be in this shot?
Like?
Or?
Two.
Look how far we've come.
Clear eyes.
Numb knees.
Can't lose, let's hit it.
You wrote all of the songs on the album.
So if everybody hates it,
it means that they hate you
as a person on every level.
-Jesus, Summer.
-What?
Oh, no.